[Music]
[Applause]
we're starting our trip we're planning
our trip to ireland
navy notre dame next year this time
because we saw that uh northwestern and
nebraska were playing there and we
thought okay now we thought about a trip
a couple of years ago and uh we were
actually doing uh doing an interview
with jason sudeikis and he was promoting
i think ted lasso at the time and then
will ferrell called in because he heard
us talking about it interrupted the
interview and then said that he'd like
to join us if we went to uh dublin
and then somehow it just didn't work out
will's schedule got busy probably
shooting a movie with mark wahlberg or
kevin hart or somebody
but uh apparently will ferrell is back
in the trip to dublin do you have to
clear this with your wife will
oh no she's coming
right we're bringing our wives um
no it's just bros i think
hey um
i just got to clear something up okay uh
i here's i don't know if this is
exciting or sad i was not listening to
your show when i called in i i just
called in randomly
i was driving my car i had no idea
you're on with sedakis that was just
that was just kismet
wait are you serious that you didn't
i had no idea
you
but
something popped into my head where we
had talked about it
that's
at a past point i'm like god i gotta
remind dan
i'm gonna remind him on air we're like
when are we going to dublin
and then um oh that's funny
i call in and i think it was paul you
picked up he's like you went in on this
i'm like sure i have no idea what he's
talking about
and uh
poor jason sudeikis he's like uh
couldn't he couldn't you uh
maybe send him an email
you sent an
and
email
i think we
we briefly talked about uh snl
basketball games okay now i want you to
be serious though because you got to
clear your schedule for next august i
don't know it's august right august 26th
i believe i've already got it down
okay
um we can stay okay so let's see
it's you and me
it's it's paulie it's fritz right marvin
seton and marvin t okay
and we gotta try to wrangle jennifer
gardner right that's michael garner yes
okay
okay now okay can you help us get some
other celebrities we should stay at the
clarence hotel the you you know bono's
hotel okay now we're talking now we're
making
the temple bar district i like that
a lot a lot of great bars a lot of we
can
we can be we can sing a lot of pogues
songs as we ramble through the streets
right do you know okay let's go around
the room uh
paulie wanted to bring paul rudd it
seems like a great time
oh right red
rod rudd is in already i don't even have
to ask him his
his dad built
an authentic irish pub in the basement
of his house in kansas city i've been
there
yeah i'm going to believe you todd
oh todd's on the phone uh jennifer
garner uh
what was brought up do you do you know
jennifer garner like can you i don't
okay i'm gonna have to work on that okay
we got a year uh who else did we put in
there uh seaton i had uh colin farrell
calling farrell we might need a man on
the streets
what do you think i want i
i would love to uh
we got to be related in some way i would
think right
i would think colin and and will ferrell
distant cousins uh even though you know
we spell the name differently that
doesn't matter it's just that you know
in ireland they spell it differently you
know it's gaelic there todd wanted to
bring liam neeson
i've i've met liam he's a great guy um
uh he'd be good if we need muscle he's
uh you know yeah
it's like taken four
are we gonna
are we gonna be getting a lot of fights
i feel like we are we we i'm i'm hoping
we are
can you when's the last time you were in
a real fight
uh third grade okay all right
did you get your ass kicked yeah i got
punched in the stomach with one shot
richie brooks
um
i said something sarcastic and he just
he punched me in the stomach knocked the
wind out of me dropped me to my knees i
said okay
uh marvin who did you want to bring
i said liam neeson oh liam neeson okay
okay so um who did i say that i wanted
to bring there i i
i think i said will was i was gonna
bring him
uh no you're just saying that that's
true
yeah uh when's the last time you were in
dublin
i was there this summer
i was there uh
with a group of friends we did a little
golf trip it was fantastic we were in
the
um i can get us a private tour of the
guinness factory i don't know if you can
pull that off no i cannot but i like
that um private tasting room where we
learn how to actually pour the
the pints of guinness how about we get
daniel day lewis because he retired from
acting
and he can also teach us how to make
cobble shoes
um does wahlberg ever take time off
wahlberg loves golf i don't know if he
drinks anymore but he might be a good
guy he
possibly i don't i i don't think he has
the bandwidth or the attention span to
you know hang out and then go to the
foot because are we going to the game as
well yes right yes okay notre dame navy
now i'm gonna have to pull for navy dnsd
guy
oh
yeah okay i mean it's fine
once we get to the stadium
with the cadets you'll just go to their
side and then we'll go to notre dame's
side
then i'll meet you afterwards speak
after me after okay
i'm planning this now
i'm i'm all in
okay all in i'm not just saying this
are you are
i'm gonna say we are we doing the show
yes
thursday and friday yeah thursday and
friday
okay i think we fly in wednesday
we'll get there wednesday morning that
means we go tuesday night to get there
wednesday morning
so let's see we're going to need
okay we're going to need at least two
king size beds right a couple roll aways
we're all staying in one room right i'd
hope
yeah
great
great um
know we'll figure out the bathroom
situation are you can you drink are you
any good at drinking
um i can i can uh
i can hold hold myself with the best
yeah
i'm just gonna have you
well you were
were you drunk you were drunk in old
school you had to uh give the impression
you were drunk at old school correct
i had to give the impression yeah i was
uh
um
well
the
the the scene that leads into the
streaking the uh
um snoop dogg's performance yeah that
was
that was taking so long that was our
last night of shooting that was taking
so long
to get snoop dogg out of his trailer
because in between takes he'd go back
and play video games and
he would uh partake he'd get high
yes
and uh
so it was just slowing the whole thing
down so
i just uh
i started drinking
yeah did you get high with snooze no no
no just just
just kept having a few beers and uh
so by the time i uh
that's what encouraged me trying to take
uh bishop dawn mack's hat off his head
ooh
but that that didn't that didn't go well
i didn't like that that's not acting on
his part
that's not acting it that's an honest
reaction
all right so
so we're in 11 and a half months to
prepare for this yeah
what could go wrong
nothing week a week i know wonderful
walking tours of dublin we can look at
the book of kells have you ever seen
that yes i have yeah yes yes i think i
think the i think the guys would enjoy
that yeah
uh yeah and
i don't know if you can bring your your
beer into the book of kells but you know
no you can't oh you can't because you
might spill it on the book of kelly's
yeah and uh that would uh that would
ruin
thousands of years of history all right
no wives on this trip i mean
let's have some fun
um
i'm trying to think anything else i just
got to work on uh jennifer gardner no
garner
garner not gardner
oh
with jennifer garner in the meantime
then
this is why we have these discussions so
we're all on point here yes jennifer
garner
no d no
d
when i meet her i'll go jennifer garner
no d right
okay all right well all right we'll be
in touch
uh let's keep checking in okay see if
there's any changes all right that
sounds great that's right that's that's
2023 is our year
in 2023 in dublin all right thank you
will thanks dan that's will ferrell
okay
okay it's going well yeah i think
you know the planning stages i feel
pretty good about this